you're right Evelyn whoa Evelyn where'd
you grow up are you from originally I'm
from a river town called Richland
Washington news that near Seattle it
downwind from Seattle New Hampshire
Washington where metal cars and
refrigerators are made until about your
childhood yet both your parents yes I
did had an elderly father and that
brunette mother how was how was your
childhood it was fine lots of running in
early dance lessons with the Russian
masters what kind of what kind of kid
were you in high school uh I was an
early listener I would come in at about
two o'clock in the afternoon not wanting
to be in sweated clothes or slip on the
death and I would put my feet up there's
a desk and not look around and the first
word was Paris reveal and we were able
to travel the ski lodges that summer and
see the mountains as they were iced up
and we just wore short sleeve t-shirts
in our exposure in teenage years and
went to the desert after that out for
some nude running and found myself near
a shop returned homes address and found
myself in a long buggy dress and hung it
out on the line and the woman appeared
and she Gerda being my sister Jean and
she taught me sewing from a black enamel
Singer sewing machine and it kept the
house cool and we poured pledge that
Christmas and my brother appeared and
he's now a minister a glide memorial
hospital so your childhood sounds pretty
good yeah not a lot of time at my
parents says I had to make my own money
from my future college I had a set of my
heart
and the youngster to remain with Bucky
with my mother and father were to the
parts or accident or injury and my elder
sister took me into her home for three
years as I watched her growing through
her early marriage now she's been
married up for past six 55 years how do
you I'm 61 have you been married and no
I haven't your children yes I do I -
then did you raise them yes yes I did
along with my sisters and my three
brothers also have children and he
played and they saw the toys out so
today you're living in the Tenderloin
yeah San Francisco wha how long you been
hit living here uh since the year 2000
stopping in front of the pop shop and
getting cherry cola she's very cool chit
chat chit chit Cola
yeah and that brought the train to a
stop is it nearly went off the road and
and I was able to hang on the dumb
sports those are all meal lines and
click those are you ready on the streets
with a squiggle straw yeah mostly to
keep the roof up is on a weight lifter
in my New York years running track and
shooting baskets and then that brought
me home to my father's old globe head
and he didn't take me honey he told me
the sky is falling and I went in the
back and found a typewriter he's a
Electrical Engineering from about the
Year 1919 and I was able to write a soul
screenplay called the sky is blue and
took a to New York and deposit visit in
the glow in the Benjamin Franklin Mint
and it came up as diamond earrings and
elevator and I was in that elevator
rising to NBC Studios where I met Donald
Trump do you do the attempt today I've
been in two-tenths did not enjoy the
squeeze condition
so you're basically under just living on
the street now without a tent yeah do a
little zipper job they're noticing a
black hat really different ain't that
too hot so I said Keith Sweat and did
like the black guys do and paddled out
on my own
do you have rough things happen to you
here on stress things
no the worst I've had is a cigarette
butt into my inner thigh and that was
looking at a boy's hand to kept a pipe
in his hands fearing arrest some citizen
officers they can be dressed in day
clothes or as your fine pizza dinner
followed by root beer and coke and that
will make an officer if you're in need
of a parent but if you have your parents
in then they can speak to them for you
is your dragged through the court system
everyone do you use any of the drugs
that are on the street I use marijuana
from things like McDonald's wrappers
though so bless you can leave a chunk of
beef in there and your way to find your
marijuana or cigarette have you ever you
ever been in a mental health facility
facility or anything
yes I'll involuntarily to get the
temperature of my outdoor body and was
able to walk out with black shoes and
take a bus ride to a minor key shop
where I saw the Japanese hostesses was
there sherbert hair that is running
sweat
yes their toddlers were curbed to the
street and netted behind their bass
probably nauseous and overheated maybe
an infant mortality and I went
got to the hospital to get sir monitors
and band-aids and sounds them just
outside the door and was lucky to get
away again because mental institutions
are mostly MC Hammer are all serial
skips those little Cheerios those will
make a nurse in a hurry left on the
floor I love this yeah a double bed is
your family no they here don't does your
family know you're living here on the
stroll yes I wrote them for about 12
years and easy dozen pieces of paper
were rolled up and made into smoking
papers which I deposited into a rake for
the parks and that mean my uncle coming
up from Milwaukee an old beer drinking
town where the Buffalo will come to the
back door and grace then that to the
bartender and he'll look like a Grateful
Dead member with their guitar strung
around the Nashville sweating aft and
the bugs coming from the laces of the
the cords
those are old Keith that had been
screwing around the California pools
everyone how do you how do I spell my
mate no how do you uh how do you support
yourself how do you make money from tech
disbursement I have no Florida
transportation in me I wish by their and
was able to see me work again just by
missing Florida thank God and education
in the banking meaning B's and Gulf
sniffing or throwing a scarf around your
neck to hide your last whereabouts and
people weren't able to follow me as I
picked up pennies and toots
stuck together made a quarter for those
and Mountain Dew drink
made a dollar as you have to be warm
cool hot the marijuana will make you so
I don't know there smoke on them that'll
burn up green money do you have any
friends I have five friends my son is my
bodyguard now see grow stronger sir free
eat or depositing your nice verbal
messages like good morning have a nice
day see you later alligator and that'll
make steps or an elevator and my sister
I think went to Florida that was able to
photograph the alligators climbing out
of the swamps and that made the
milkshakes come up and I missed those so
my safety net large and I was able to be
photographed with my spring play and
Donald Trump then my screenplay just
turned into rolling paper and cigarettes
but at one time it was a Sony jewel
making a marquee as I held it up for a
taxi driver he whisked me off to the
early Bronx or where the cab stops
preferring chocolate is payment in the
early years now he accepts cash but
riding around and the black interior
will sir make me get a spring up and
those boys are just paid in Nelkin Oh
cereal right happen well thank you so
much for talking with me okay comment
and good luck with wherever you go from
here wow thank you so much for your time
oh did you call me Elmer
Albert yeah uh-huh
you're very cute oh thank you
you